Giraffe was very hungry.
I don't want to eat leaves.
He said.
I always eat leaves.
Giraffe tried eating grass just like a deer.
But bending down hurt his neck.
Giraffe tried to eat ants just like an anteater.
But ants bit his tongue.
Giraffe tried eating honey just like a bear.
But bees stung his nose.
Giraffe tried to eat fish just like an otter.
But he fell in the water and got very wet.
Giraffe tried eating bugs just like a frog.
But his tongue was not fast enough.
Giraffe tried to eat seeds just like a bird.
But his lips were too big to pick up the seeds.
Giraffe was still hungry.
He bit into the green leaves hanging from the tree.
Delicious!
He said.
Leaves are the best food.